[Música]
es el final el último modelo o es el
final casi me gustaría poder casarme de
nuevo con mi marido es decir no casarme
con otra persona porque te refieres a
empezar de nuevo empezar de nuevo no he
dicho volver a casarse
esto significa pero ponerme esto
necesito quiero decir es que es un
vestido con el que solo quieres vivir al
ver
increíble normalmente los desfiles de
alta costura terminan con el vestido de
novia pero esto fue super interesante
esta forma de convocar a la naturaleza
como una etérea hiedra venenosa
increíble
hiedra venenosa esa villana que nos
encanta odiar la archienemiga de batman
incapaz de entrar en simbiosis con las
plantas pero por muy bonita que sea esta
referencia no es el mundo de los
superhéroes el que ha inspirado a maria
grazia chiuri para su colección de alta
costura invierno 2021 es más
sencillamente el hilo conductor el punto
de partida de toda la ropa esto se
refleja en el bordado de este enorme
fresco de 95 metros de largo
señalado por la artista francesa eva
joly
watson rose ella
hay cerca de 400 tonos y hay casi diario
150 variaciones de puntos así que es
enorme es realmente vertiginoso y
espero que la gente quiera mirarlo y
sobre todo a acercarse perderse los
detalles querer tocarlos porque eso es
lo que quiero hacer cuando lo mira
quiero poner las manos encima y perderme
en todos los puntos en todas las
variaciones me parece increíble
intenté abordar cuando intérprete la
heredera en broadway
mi personaje bordaba pero fue un
desastre se necesitaba una habilidad
específica y para hacerlo bonito hace
falta tiempo es un arte
me siento absolutamente incapaz de hacer
algo así y por eso estoy tan contenta de
poder contemplarlo
[Música]
maria grazia chiuri celebre el trabajo
manual esta particular emoción que
siente en contacto con los materiales
sus diferentes texturas que mezcla para
disponer de caídas singulares
[Música]
empecé a investigar sobre el tuit de
cachemira para crear un bonito tweet
como i suyo en los años 50 en lana
utilizamos el mismo palo para hacer
bonitos tejidos del punto excepto
y con este hilo mezclado con diferentes
tejidos hicimos tratos bolsos sombreros
como insumisión yo al principio de su
carrera la alta costura es algo
excepcional estoy muy contenta y
orgullosa de que podamos hacer este tipo
de colecciones
vestidos de lana en espiga faldas
bordadas con plumas malla de poliamida
entretejida con microcristales
me encantó la mezcla de estilos los
tweets y los cascos de excitación me
encantó esta mezcla de mujeres y hombres
y por supuesto los vestidos es preciosa
tan romántico y fluido y todos los
últimos diseños el verde el vestido
final con las hojitas dentro fue hermoso
tan romántico
la fibra textil es maleable múltiple en
constante metamorfosis como la
naturaleza la diseñadora india by
charlie adam google lo ha convertido en
caballo de batalla su colección es un
homenaje a nuestro medio ambiente jaime
fabric sites night traerán a christmas
diseño mis propias telas y elijo no si
los creo en mi propio tejido y mantengo
su grosor para asegurar su caída por
supuesto las texturas la inspiración de
la naturaleza así que puede que hayan
visto muchos árboles setas corales
diferentes elementos de la naturaleza
todas esas texturas diferentes es
posible que hayan visto muchas cuerdas
en mi ropa como si influyera un arroyo
cuando ven el agua o cualquier cosa en
la naturaleza sienten ese flujo no es
así solo intento expresarme así
combinando lo humano y la naturaleza hay
que estar muy conectado con la
naturaleza así es como se puede vivir
naturaleza y futuro la joven diseñadora
parisina aclarada gun teje el vínculo
entre el saber a ser manual y el
progreso técnico su colección denominada
oráculo está patrocinada por google
hilos de fibra óptica circuitos bordados
módulos de radiofrecuencia una simbiosis
entre ciencia y misticismo la colección
de hackers la colección de este año
incluye cinco piezas así que tenemos el
oráculo que es la pieza central que hará
interactuar a los otros cuatro que los
rodean que son los cuatro elementos
tierra aire fuego y agua así el oráculo
lleva unos guantes interactivos con
tecnologías jackass bordada en su
interior lo que hace que el guante sea
capacitivo de hecho cuando acerca la
mano al guante éste detecta su presencia
y hace que los vestidos que los rodean
reaccionen y se iluminen
una proeza técnica cuya mayor dificultad
era hacer reaccionar las fibras en
tiempo real
y el bordado y la electrónica se diseñan
al mismo tiempo para que el circuito
siga la forma del bordado para que éste
tenga en cuenta todas las limitaciones
técnicas del circuito
y
estas colecciones de alta costura
representan a la vez un retorno a
nuestras raíces y una exploración de las
fronteras del presente entre la
tradición textil y el progreso técnico
una nueva visión de la moda del mañana